[موسيقى]
صباح الفجر فوق نهر النيل
في مصر في مشهد تكرر لقرون ،
وانزلاق دا جابر الأنيق في المشهد في القرن
التاسع عشر ، كان الأثرياء الأوروبيون
يركبون قوارب الركاب الأنيقة هذه في رحلة بحرية
من القاهرة إلى الأقصر هذه الأيام ،
ينجذب نوع جديد من المسافرين إلى  النهر
بحثًا عن التجديد الروحي ، فإن
الرحلة البحرية هي من بنات أفكار
طبق كريستوف بيجلر وإيزابيل بيترز بالنسبة لي إذا تحقق
، إنه بحث عن
سلامك الخاص عندما تكون غير متصل
على النيل ، كل شيء يتغير نوعًا
ما يشبه تقريبًا أنك في  فقاعة ، إنه
مكان يمكنك فيه أن تولد من جديد ،
والفرق بين الرحلة
الكلاسيكية وهذه الرحلة هو أنه بالإضافة إلى
المعابد الجميلة لديك الطبيعة الجميلة ،
نحاول أيضًا المساعدة في شفاء
شخصك الداخلي لعلي ألفي ، فالهدوء على
متن القارب هو
فترة راحة في الوقت المناسب من حياته المزدحمة في القاهرة ،
لذا سبحت على نهر النيل بأكمله
وخاصة هنا في الأسفل ، إنه أمر ساحر للغاية ،
ومن الجيد دائمًا الخروج من المدينة
والتواصل ليس مع الطبيعة فحسب ، بل
هذه الأماكن التي
تشحن حقًا المجموعة التي تبحر من الأقصر بعد
معبد الكرنك ووادي
الملوك عبر الأقفال المعقدة في
إدفو وأخيراً إلى
أسوان لعلي والآخرين على متن السفينة
بعد الظهر.  لمزيد من
التأمل واليوغا ، تستند اليوجا الوهمية
على الطريقة الروحية المصرية القديمة
للحياة عندما تسافر أو
تأتي إلى مكان مثل هذا يفتح لك ،
أليس كذلك هو فقط يمهد
الطريق لنوع التواصل الذي نحن فيه.
تبحث عن مع ممارسة مثل
التأمل أو اليوجا